Crystals are highly ordered structures.
They can be made up of atoms of ions which
are charged species
or they can be made up of molecules as well.
But what's important is that they have a very
regular arrangement.
So they could either be oriented in the same
way or they're alternating regularly.
but we're not just talking in a couple of
dimensions, we're talking a 3D structure here.
Diamonds, salt, sugar and ice, they all look
kind of colourless but they've all got a crystalline
structure.
Diamond is made of highly ordered Carbon atoms.
The sodium-chloride that makes up your salt
is made of sodium and chloride ions
that have been arranged in a 3D structure
that repeats again and again, but also ice.
Now ice and sugar, they're not atoms and they're
not ions but they are molecules,
and these molecules are able to order themselves
against one another and around one another.
Entropy, as dictated by the second law of
thermodynamics means that
things tend to move towards a more disordered
state
and you would think that crystals are disobeying
that law of thermodynamics because effectively
you're creating order.
What's actually happening though is that as
a crystal forms, it often releases heat
and so that energy isn't just sort of staying
within that system, it is being redistributed.
So it's the redistribution of heat which is
actually the increase in entropy that we're
seeing
even though the physical ordering of these
bits of matter is increasing.
When we think about a thermodynamic problem
like this, it's easy to presume that it is
a closed system,
but actually you can't just think of the problem
in isolation from the rest of your lab,
or your city, or the world.
You're actually thinking about it as one part
of a system the size of the universe.
So really, these entropy issues are way bigger
than you can confine in your lab.